[Music]
thank you
now let's turn to America where on
Tuesday President Joe Biden announced
that he would be running for re-election
in the presidential election next year
this surprised nobody we even told you
that The Spectator back in January on
our cover that this was going to happen
and I think it's also fair to say that
it hasn't really excited anybody as well
I'm joined Now by Grace Curley who is
host of The Grace curly show
um Grace A lot of people are talking
about this but it's worth reflecting on
a majority of Democrats
um don't want Joe Biden to run
um a huge majority of young Democrats
don't want
um Joe Biden to run I think something
like 76 of 18 to 34 year olds don't
think he should run
um and yet here we are we're approaching
um and he's going to run why
I think he's going to run I was thinking
about it over the weekend because almost
the opposite reasons why Trump is
running so Trump has a lot of enthusiasm
with voters people really
um they feel connected to Trump they
feel this loyalty to Trump with Biden
it's the opposite so I think with Biden
it's the establishment who's very happy
with his performance they like having
somebody who's really just kind of a
puppet who they can pull the strings you
know he's not going to fight back he's
not going to give them a hard time he
really doesn't know what's going on and
so they like having that person in there
who they can boss around now as you said
the enthusiasm from voters might not be
there but the establishment and and the
swamp really as far as Democrats go who
are in charge they don't care they don't
care if the voters they know the voters
will vote for him I mean that's the big
difference here there's a difference
between
lacking enthusiasm and people not
actually going out and voting for you
and I just because Democrats aren't
excited about him I don't think they're
they're going to not
vote for him can you be precise
particularly for mostly British viewers
we think uh what is the establishment in
America what is the swamp who are these
people who have decided that Joe Biden
is it not Joe Biden has decided that Joe
Biden is going to run again
no I think that there's a lot of you
know power players in the Democrat Party
a lot of like Senator Chuck Schumer and
then you have these Congress people who
have a lot of power on social media I
think they have a big sway in what
actually happens in DC and so that's
what I mean when I say The Establishment
I mean people surrounding Joe Biden who
are the decision makers because I don't
think he's a decision maker and I think
if and probably you know what probably
there's a mix two of
the media is involved as well because I
think if the media had wanted to
and they had softened the soil a little
bit going into this they could have
taken Joe Biden down with his scandals
but they covered for him and so I think
a combination of Joe's colleagues in DC
and also the media kind of running cover
for him have allowed him to seek another
term as president
and what it leaves us with is a
situation where the majority I mean Joe
Biden and indeed Hillary Clinton did win
a popular majority let's not get into
the specifics of the both of those
elections but uh the majority of people
who have voted Democrats in the past are
left with a candidate
um who they don't like I don't know if
you know the comedian Bo Burnham but he
had a very good song called Joe Biden
where he sang they're really going to
make me vote for Joe Biden that was back
in 2020 uh it's going to be exactly the
same thing in 2024. and uh a lot of
people I've done a piece about it myself
this week are thinking this speaks to
some great dysfunction in American
democracy that unpopular presidents just
carry on
what do you think about that
yeah
I guess it's just kind of sad like I was
thinking about that as well I mean 2020
we had we're probably gonna have the
exact same match up and uh it's
it kind of shows it's it's very
uninspiring to put it mildly and I
understand why young voters are
frustrated too because they're a lot of
these young Democrats are very radical
they're very Progressive and there's
plenty of people who are kind of
climbing the ranks who have been dying
to have the torch passed to them but I
think what
there was a really good piece by Victor
I think it was Victor Davis Hanson in
American greatness and he kind of wrote
about how
it's a good way when you have these
older Democrats who a lot of younger
people would consider boring and you
know past their Prime
not to I don't want to Don Lemon myself
I just mean you know they're in their
80s
um it's a nice way for Democrats to be
able to put up this front that we're old
school look at you know we still kind of
are catering to the center you know
middle of the road Democrat even if
they're not so I think that that's a
part of it too which the young people
probably it frustrates them but it is a
smart Play Because as much as they want
a younger person in there who's just
going to tell it like it is and really
tell the voters exactly what they want
to hear you're better off with the Joe
Biden who can at least pretend to be
this old grandfather you know who's
working across the aisle and used to get
a beer with people who are conservatives
and
that kind of cover for Democrats
actually works in their favor
an interesting element is Joe Biden's
vice president who is of course Kamala
Harris who as everybody probably knows
by now is even less popular than Joe
Biden uh and has widely seen to be a
fairly inept Veep uh there is some
speculation that Biden could drop her
um and pick a more
um exciting or uh successful or
inspiring candidate for 2024
um which might uh address some of the
concerns about his second term because
if if uh if he's going to be 86 by the
time he finishes his second term if his
health Fades even more
you may get a situation where the vice
president has to step up and become the
president so who he chooses if he drops
Kamala Harris uh will become very very
important do you think it's possible or
likely that he will drop Kamala Harris
and who might he choose
no I don't think it's possible I never
thought it was
it was started I just don't think
there's
that you can do that without really
upsetting like a lot of those voters we
just talked about they might not be
excited about Kamal Harris they may not
love her but they love getting mad about
things they love being offended they
love you know outrage and
um giving Kamala Harris the boot would
definitely cause a lot of
um
frustration and anger and I've I've read
things before about people saying like
oh you know he could just he could pick
another black woman to come in there's
you know because there's so many
um and I'm not denying that that there's
plenty of candidates
but that to me seems really
um like he's just using people at that
point if you're just taking one person
and swapping them out for another and
you think that uh these black women are
interchangeable that to me seems like a
really dangerous road to go down and if
I were Kamala Harris or any of her fans
she might not have a lot of fans but I
would be offended I I would I would take
that as a huge insult so I don't think
he's gonna go near that I think he's
just gonna they're gonna play the same
the same thing they did in 2020 it
worked so why mess with a good thing I
guess
you said that you think uh the
Republican nominee who the person who
Joe Biden will probably face next year
is probably going to be Donald Trump uh
We've taught the Forum spectator TV
we've covered it quite a lot in the
magazine uh about Governor Ron DeSantis
the governor of Florida
um
obviously Trump has this very
significant lead in the polls quite how
much we can read into the polls at this
early stage is a matter of debate
um do you think Ron DeSantis chances of
being underrated at the moment or
overrated
underrated I think the fact that he
hasn't even
officially thrown his hat in the ring
yet he hasn't really given us his 100
attempt at this I wouldn't count him out
I think we still have a long way to go I
mean people forget in 2016 before those
debates it the the landscape the field
was totally different nobody had Donald
Trump on their bingo card so a lot can
change when you start to see these
candidates interact and America gets a
real look at who their who they're
potentially picking
um I I think that
there is this Rush from Republicans to
just choose and have it done with and
you know it's it's Trump and there's no
other way to go but I kind of think
we're doing ourselves a disservice and
I'm honest I'm a conservative so if
anyone out there I'm fully Republican so
I I just think that where um
we're eliminating our options very early
and I don't think that's a smart
strategic move
uh the census is sort of Ace card if you
like would be Trump fatigue
um that a lot of Voters uh are fed up of
all the drama about Trump they they look
they may like him they may even love him
but they may think uh we've been beaten
uh three times in a row arguably
Nationwide in the midterms in 2018 in
the presidential in 2020 in the midterms
again in 2022
um and it makes more sense to move on
do you have Trump fatigue Grace curly
and do you think your the audience of
your show has Trump fatigue
the audience in my show definitely does
not have Trump fatigue um I go through
waves of it you know especially over the
last couple of months where you have
things like you have the raid at
Mar-A-Lago you have the Trump indictment
I mean you have these moments where your
Trump fatigue gets overwhelmed by your
sense of outrage about what's happening
to them so then you kind of go back into
feeling like this guy's getting screwed
I'm rooting for him and so I've kind of
fluctuated between the truth between the
two my audience has not my audience is
most for the most part very much team
Trump
um but yeah I think this is what we keep
hearing from a lot of people is DeSantis
could be Trump without all the baggage
now what then I hear if you bring that
up
from
Trump Republicans is well you're so
naive if you don't think they're going
to go after DeSantis in the same way
they've gone after Donald Trump and what
I always respond to that is I am not
stupid I know they're going to go after
DeSantis they've already tried multiple
times with these crazy stories about him
what I think it comes down to is who can
handle that better and who can kind of
not get distracted by that as much and
that's where I think desantises appeal
lies is that he has an ability to not
get too sucked in to a lot of these
small fights and small arguments yes
well one potentially very big fight is
on the issue of abortion
um because of Donald Trump and because
of the justices he put on the Supreme
Court last summer we had the Dobbs
decision which overturned Roe v Wade and
the legal right to the federal right to
an abortion in America and yet since
that's happened abortion has sort of
flipped as an issue and become a big big
winner or a bigger winner than it was
for the Democrats
um in a way that is alarms Republican
strategist because you're seeing a lot
of progressive women and young people
going out and voting in ways they didn't
before for the Democrats because they
want to stop the republican-led
challenge to abortion Ron DeSantis
recently signed a six-week Bill uh sorry
Banning a ban on abortions after six
weeks in Florida
and Trump has been strangely muted on
abortion of late and in fact in I think
his latest statement on it he said this
is rightly a state's issue
um how is that going to play out on the
Republican side
it almost reminds what Trump is doing
with DeSantis kind of reminds me of what
a lot of Republicans oh I'm sorry a lot
of Democrats do with Donald Trump where
they get so focused on the person that
their policies change based off what he
does and so if he reverses course then
Democrats tend to want to do the
opposite of whatever he's doing I think
DeSantis is kind of having that effect
on Trump where he wants to be against
DeSantis so he's changing a lot of the
things that he's been saying over the
last couple of years
um this this issue though is so tricky
and I I saw today that Nikki Haley said
that you know the country needs to come
to a consensus on abortion and she
thinks she knows how to do it and I just
don't understand how that happens like I
don't
I don't see how
because I I've been seeing Democrats and
Republicans saying well you know if if
these candidates could just kind of move
to the center and change their stances a
little bit then they might win over
voters
and that's fine if you're a candidate
who really doesn't believe what you're
saying and there are people who feel in
the middle about abortion I'm kind of
one of those people I don't tend to have
a super strong opinion but if you are a
republican who has a strong belief that
abortion is killing an unborn human
then how do you move to the middle on
that like how do you how do you convince
someone to kind of just abandon that for
the sake of you know widening the tent
and I'm not trying to sound holier than
now I'm just saying I don't I don't see
how we can come to a consensus on
something that for a lot of people in
this country is black and white one way
or the other
if uh Donald Trump
does win the nomination do you think he
will has a better chance of beating Joe
Biden than Ron DeSantis would
no no I don't
um
I I think
but if I were really to guess I would
say Rhonda Santos probably has a better
chance of beating Joe Biden because
there's a lot of people who um I I guess
it's I don't think the left will be able
to
kind of gin up the same hatred for Ron
DeSantis in the short amount of time as
they did for Donald Trump that to me
feels like lightning in a bottle that
kind of trump derangement syndrome is
going to be hard to duplicate with
somebody else and it's going to be hard
for the media to tell people oh this
guy's actually worse than Donald Trump
you thought Trump was bad we told you
Trump was a dictator but this new guy
who seems to be a family man and he's
pretty low-key and he doesn't go on
Twitter a lot he's actually worse than
Trump I just think there's a lot of
people in the center who aren't going to
buy that and so I think that the
combination of that and the fact that
DeSantis is a lot younger and he could
really showcase that on the debate stage
against Joe Biden I think that's that's
a win in his column I think the polls so
far as to who would win in a matchup
DeSantis Biden or Trump Biden are quite
mixed at the moment
um but probably the reason why Trump
might have more of an advantage is that
he has always been able to drive out low
propensity voters
um and because of his name recognition
because of the people that a lot of
people the fact that a lot of people who
don't normally vote do vote for him and
I suppose there is doubts about whether
DeSantis would be able to do that what
do you think about that
yeah I think that's valid and and I
think that
this is why you have to have a primary
and you have to kind of keep an open
mind like I keep trying to remind people
there's nothing wrong with wanting to
see people actually
debate things in a primary and decide
who you like after watching all of the
candidates and for example I like Ron
DeSantis I have no idea if he could
handle questions on foreign policy I
mean there's a whole
there's a whole section of things that
he hasn't really had to tackle as the
governor of Florida so that would be
good to that'd be good to know it'd be
good to know where he stands on a lot of
these issues and it would be good to
hear him respond to a lot of these
criticisms from Donald Trump and you
know voice whether or not they're even
valid to begin with but that whole
process I'm noticing Americans have a
lot less patience for now people people
don't seem to want that at all so
they've already kind of chosen their
sides in a lot of these cases
Grace I think we'll end it there but I
should say because obvious probably
won't be able to spot it but you are
eight months pregnant so uh the next
time you come on spectator TV you will
have a baby uh I well I don't know women
have you on sooner who knows
um but uh all the best with everything
and very nice to see you
[Music]
thank you